Okay, let's get to hatred mail. This may be
the rare left wing hatred mail at least to
some extent. Before we get to that, a quick
reminder of what hatred mail is
because it's time to make America hate again.
Hey Tree at [inaudible] written by patriots
who hate David Pacman because America and
because freedom.
So we, I, I recently was hearing from a few
people who said, do you ever get left wing
hate mail? And I do, but it often does not
lend itself to hatred mail. I think that this
week's hatred mail may qualify as left-wing
hatred. Mail. Take a listen to this.
I'm not a fan of Trump bleeds. Ooh, soy boy
and TV types really get to me. President Trump
isn't doing us badly. What is the point of
criticizing? So some communist hack can get
in. Bernie Lizzy, the only damn that makes
sense is tools z and the dims already screwed
her. You'll never learn, huh? Trump 2020 is
the result. Have Fun with that. I'm leaving
the country.
So someone who is threatening to leave the
country over, Donald Trump being reelected,
who says Tulsi is the only good choice and
doesn't like what I'm doing and talks about
soy antifa stuff. This seems like the closest
to left-wing hatred mail that we've received,
right? At least to some degree, I guess it's
at least ostensibly or putatively a left wing
hatred mail. It's rare, but I guess it does
exist and here it is a apparently from a Tulsi
supporter, no less. Make sure that you know
the way to fight hatred, autism in your community,
use the coupon code. Hey Tree at 40 hat, r
I o t four zero. When you sign up@joinpacman.com
you will save 40% off of a membership and
it sends a message to the Patriots that you
will not be intimidated by their hatred. Autism,
thank you.